other peace talks Mark that took place
in Kiev here in Ukraine earlier this
month on the third and fourth of March
extraordinary reports from the Wall
Street Journal and from investigative
website bellingcat claiming that members
of the Ukrainian delegation including a
Russian billionaire Roman Abramovich
experienced symptoms of chemical
poisoning during those talks that news
only emerging emerging now weeks later
but certainly suggestions that they had
as irritation to the eyes and skin and
weren't very well by the sounds of it a
Wonder list also
reporting that they've spoken to a
source close to what happened and they
allege that Roman Abramovich lost his
eyesight for a period of time and had to
be treated at a hospital in Turkey
so that news are just breaking in the
last half an hour or so mark that
billionaire Raymond Abramovich who was
involved in peace talks uh here in
Ukraine on the third and fourth of March
experienced symptoms of suspected
chemical weapons poisoning according to
those reports along with two senior
members of the Ukrainian team a little
bit more detail on the sort of symptoms
that they experienced Mark it's being
described as red eyes constant and
painful tearing as well as peeling skin
on their hands and faces so we're still
to get that confirmed ourselves Mark but
certainly an extraordinary correct claim
there that members of the Ukrainian
delegation involved in peace talks in
Kiev on the third and fourth of March
along with Russian billionaire Roman
Abramovich may have may have had
suspected chemical poisoning we'll bring
you more on that as we get it